so far you've defined the profile entity
class in your application but you don't
actually yet do anything with it the
next step is to add the code to save
profiles in the data store
you've already been working in the
conference api.java class and remember
that it defines the save profile method
which doesn't actually yet do any saving
but it will when we're done with it
the next step is to actually write the
code
that saves the entity in the data store
and it's marked in the file for you as
to do three but before i set you loose
to do that i just want to review how to
save entities in the data store using
objectify okay so we're going to look at
how to save entities in the data store
using objectify
you use the objectify service
the the offi method you call the save
method
call the entity method passing the
entity to actually save and then now
the now means go ahead and do it right
now it's usual practice to define a
static offi method so you can simplify
the code like this
just call offi
so if you remember we talked about
recipes a little while ago here's how
you might save a recipe
so this assumes that we've created a
recipient bound to the variable recipe
one so we just pass in recipe one as the
entity to save
and there it is